Senator Jeff Flake follows in the
footsteps of his maverick Arizona
colleague John McCain he's never afraid
to piss off Republican voters the latest
example flake on a book tour for his
conscience of a conservative and obvious
play on former Arizona senator Barry
Goldwater's conscience of a conservative
has been ripping president Trump up and
down the book itself doesn't pull
punches flake says that Trump was quote
a candidate who entertained voters and
offered oversimplified answers in an
op-ed for Politico flake wrote quote we
created him and now we're rationalizing
him when will that stop that unnerving
silence in the face of an erratic
executive branch is an abdication and
those in positions of leadership their
particular responsibility so has Blake
earned the respect of Democrats for his
willingness to go it alone have
Democrats cheered reflects a parent's
intrepidity have they celebrated flake
for speaking what they perceived to be
hard truths about Trump of course not
they rip them up and down from
continuing to vote for conservative
Policy Priorities here's the Twitter
take quote voting in line with the guy
you criticize is literally the opposite
of intellectual honesty David Greenwald
thanks for your op-ed Jeff Flake now
back it up with reality on the Senate
floor you're just too dishonest to cat
with bat here's Alex Shepherd in the New
Republic quote in this respect
conscience of a conservative maybe the
most clear-eyed and righteous takedown
of Donald Trump from a Republican in
office what the reader may not know
about Jeff Flake and which he certainly
doesn't reveal in his short book is that
he's voted with Donald Trump 95% of the
time according to 538 this is the
problem for the left they don't expect
intellectual honesty from Republicans
they expect submission they want
Republicans not merely to criticize
obvious moral failings within the party
or buck Trump on policy heresies they
want Republicans to vote for Democratic
priorities in order to fight Trump which
is pretty convenient since they'd like
Republicans to vote for Democratic
priorities anyway if Trump were to push
single-payer would they applaud
Republicans for voting it down this is
one of the big reasons Trump actually
won in 2016
Republicans got tired of hearing that
they must hold themselves to a higher
standard when any standard other than
complete surrenders to Democrats is
insufficient to Democrats Democrats
could cheer Ted Kennedy and praise him
as the conscience of the Senate
Democrats could openly state that Bill
Clinton's myriad moral monstrosity or
just fine and dandy so long as he
protected the killing of the unborn
our Republicans are expected to condemn
immoral behavior and abandon their own
principles if not they're hypocrites the
predictable result a Republican Party
that embraces the Democrats logic
this should be a lesson for
conservatives no matter how
intellectually honest you are with
regard to your own side no matter what
moral standard you hold them - you'll be
castigated alongside those whose
behavior you condemn if you share
political priorities that's not an
excuse to toss morality out the window
but it's certainly a reminder that the
leftist priority here is not a more
decent country but a more leftist one
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show is this real life is this just
fantasy he was just a poor boy nobody
loved him
Anthony Ciara Moochie hits the skids he
is down to the White House and I am
hardest hit I mean normally the neuro
Times says things like world to end
tomorrow blacks and women hardest hit
well Anthony Skinner Moochie out of the
White House Ben Shapiro shot hardest hit
because we love that dude I am so sad it
does make you question the president's a
benevolent God in the universe we're
fasting and today's the Jewish fasted
mode solemn day on the Jewish calendar
that is tisha Bob will talk about that a
little bit later but I'm also quasi
fasting for the ouster of Anthony to get
our mochi I just can't believe it in
fact in moment I want to do some special
tribute Anthony Skinner motion but first
I have to say hello to our advertisers
over at my Patriot supply so if you are
concerned about the situation in the
world if you are worried that North
Korea now has a missile that can hit
half the United States if you are
worried that the Russians are getting
more aggressive if you're worried that
the Chinese are getting more aggressive
if you're worried that we're living in
an economic bubble if you're worried
that there could be some sort of natural
disaster you need obviously provide for
your family and that means you have to
have enough food on hand to take care of
your family in case the grocery stores
run bare or in case the in case they
shut their doors right now you can get
their new survival food supply for only
$99 it includes 102 servings breakfasts
lunches and dinners for less than a
dollar per serving order now at 888 803
1413 888 803 1413 or online and prepare
with Ben comm it's just $99 plus free
shipping my Patriot supply the food
tastes apparently like home cooking
folks at the office I prepare with been
calm its prepare with been calm make
sure that your family's protected your
office is protected eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen four
ninety-nine bucks seems like a good
investment to make sure that in case
something terrible happens
you are now protected and you have
enough meals for days and days and days
and days one hundred and two servings a
lot of meal so that make
sure that you and your family are safe
against prepare with been calm you don't
have to worry about bad things happening
when you're prepared prepare with been
calm okay so in just a few minutes we're
going to be having on Sinestro Susie has
a brand new book out that's already
climbing about seller charts the big lie
so have them on just a minute but first
I would be remiss if I did not pay
tribute to my favorite member of the
Trump administration so far I'm really
angry at the writers on the season of
Trump I'm really upset with the writers
on the season of Trump because I have to
say this season Trump like if you're
going to set up the Fonz you have to
keep them around for a few seasons
before you cap them you can't have the
red wedding unless you have three
seasons of Rob I mean you can't do this
guys but you know in honor of Anthony
Skinner Moochie I just want to take a
moment of silence in memoriam Anthony
Skinner Moochie the mood July 21st to
2017 July 31st to 2017 his epitaph I'm
not trying to suck my own bleep
Anthony Skinner Moche moment of silence
folks ok well that's over so the mooch
is now out and the and it's all
hilarious and ridiculous I was trying to
search for ways that this was done there
were there were stories yesterday the
mooch was ousted by John Kelly who's the
new chief of staff that he came in he
was sick of the mood the mood wanted
direct access to Trump and John Kelly
basically took him out and it looked a
little bit like this from Braveheart in
this particular scene from Braveheart
you will be seeing when the part of King
Edward Longshanks being played by John
Kelly and the part of and the part of
Anthony Skinner Moochie being played by
random advisor to the prince it does not
go well for for Anthony scare Malucci
who is this person who speaks to me as
though I needed his advice I have
declared Philips my high councilor is he
qualified I am skilled in the arts of
war and military tactics ah ah and to me
what advice would you offer on the
present
for much there he goes well that's too
bad you know that said that there goes
the mooch
John Kelly taking control now the other
one that reminded me of was was the
scene obviously from The Godfather and
John Kelly left the gun took the cannoli
[Music]
you
leave the gun take the cannolis
so legitimately yesterday at the White
House the mooch is gone I'm really upset
about this because the mooch was just
wildly entertaining I would never run
out of material if the mood should stuck
around understand that in the space of
10 days he was hired by Trump he got
Sean Spicer fired his wife left him and
then he was fired okay that's that's the
life of a fruit fly right there that's
not even like a human life it's just
amazing
so yesterday after he was fired this
shot was taken outside the White House
this is not a joke it's a natural shot
outside the White House for a couple of
security guards taking a skeleton
wheeling a skeleton outside the White
House instead everybody of course is
saying well there goes the mooch just
it's just really sad they're a bunch of
funny memes that were going around there
was one that was going around Kate
Hudson actually tweeted out How to Lose
a Guy in 10 days and it was a picture of
Trump and skerin Poochie the good news
for Skinner Moche of course is that his
tenure at the White House lasted about
five times longer than Britney Spears
marriage to Jason Allen Alexander this
is actually in a cartoon embodiment of
scaramouche she's tenure at the White
House and there he goes
so what was hilarious about all this is
it the only reason that this happened is
the blowback was so strong that
eventually Trump felt like he had to do
something it is really funny to watch
the members of the Trump administration
get fired then the various excuses that
are given for their firing so Bernie is
so Sarah Huckabee Sanders she was trying
to explain why Skinner Moochie was
ousted yesterday I will I have a bridge
in Brooklyn to sell you if you believe
this explanation for why Anthony Skinner
Moochie was let go scaramouche II said
that he had a direct line of
communication of the President
there's been some speculation that
general Kelly may try to tighten up a
number of inputs that the president has
so was something about the chain of
command
or did it have anything to do with that
interview that's Karen what you mean was
look the president certainly felt that
Anthony's comments were inappropriate
for a person in that position and he
didn't want to burden general Kelly also
with that line of succession as I think
we've made clear a few times over the
course of the last couple of days to
several be individually but general
Kelley has the full authority to operate
within the White House they all
announced a couple of maintained number
one if you truly believe that Trump was
shocked and appalled by Anthony
scaramouche's language you are so dumb I
can't even express to you how stupid you
are if you believe that okay Donald
Trump loves that stuff he loves that
stuff spent the entire campaign saying
that kind of stuff maybe that's just
that's just silly so you can say that
they wanted to bring in Kelly Kelly want
a fresh start and Kelly wanted the guy
out because of all of this but to say
that Trump was just offended by his
language I mean honest to goodness
trumping offended by his language that's
that's like saying that George Carlin
was offended by his language that's just
it no no that's just that's just silly
hey by the way it's good in my view for
the administration that Skinner Moochie
is gone Pappy Kenan feels the same way
you can't understand him the
administration he says he's glad to dig
out were too scared oh gee happen was
the general came in general Kelly and he
basically was by what scaramouche he
said in the way he said it what he said
about his colleagues this is not the
kind of operation or individual that the
general wants and his operation and he
exercised immediate and swift and
decisive command and got rid of an
individual and it sends a message I
think out to the country that you have a
man in charge who is the chief of staff
who does decide on people who are even
those close to the president
okay this is the new pet right Kelly is
the new pivot and hen Kelly
often scaramouche she is is the way that
the Trump is now going to reestablish
control over his administration so I
want to talk about the ramifications of
that in a little bit because I wonder
whether it's true or not and what Trump
is going to actually have to do in order
for this to succeed
before we do any of that I first want to
bring on friend of the program obviously
best-selling author
the creator of some of the most
successful documentaries in American
history author of the New York number
one New York Times best seller Hilary's
America and now author of the brand-new
book the big lie exposing the Nazi roots
of the American left and Nesta sees a
dinesh thanks so much for joining the
show appreciate it
hey Val eyes are good to be on the show
so I just want to jump right into the
book because I think that there's a lot
of material in there that's vital for
people to know the left is constantly
suggesting that folks on the right are
Nazis and we've seen them use this as an
excuse for punching people we've seen
them use this as an excuse for opposing
politicians they don't like but
essentially you make the contention in
your book the big lie exposing the Nazi
roots of the American left but the
American left is significantly more tied
to Nazism to National Socialism than the
American right so what's what's the
basic case for that well I'm making a
contemporary case that is sitting on top
of a historical case and the
contemporary case is very simple that
fascism at its core is the ideology of
the centralized state Mussolini put it
very well when he said nothing outside
the state the individual is in a sense
subordinate to a collective power well
that doesn't sound like modern American
conservatism it sounds a lot more like
the ideology of the progressive left
second fascist tactics now if we go and
watch these anti-fog eyes the so-called
anti-fascists they wear costumes they
wear masks and hoods they carry weapons
they not only block people and burn
things and use violence but they use
intimidation they're trying to terrorize
people into submission and into silence
they're trying to control the debate in
the public square and in the onion on
campus now does this sound like fascist
it sounds a lot like Hitler's brown
shirts or Mussolini's black shirts with
the only difference being that the old
fascist admitted who they were and the
new fascists of posing as anti-fascist
ones in issues some of what seems to me
to be the problem in terms of the
political lexicon is that European
politics and American politics are
completely dissimilar and so the Nazis
may have been right-wing in comparison
to the communist
but that doesn't mean that their
right-wing in comparison to American
conservatives are very far left in
comparison to American conservatives and
you would see members of the
conservative parties in Germany people
like von papen people like Hindenburg
all these members of the so-called
conservative parties in Germany who were
largely in favor of big government
opposing the Communists and supporting
Hitler's regime and so a lot of people
have translated that over to say okay
well American conservatism and German
conservatism circa nineteen thirty two
are exactly the same but as you make
clear in the book that's not really the
case at all yeah I think we have to back
up a little further because the first
fascist regime in the world was not
Hitler it was Mussolini Mussolini in a
sense was the founder of fascism as a
political phenomenon Mussolini was a
lifelong Marxist he was a socialist and
his fascism grew out of that
in other words Mussolini saw that the
prophecies of Marx were not coming true
and he thought that part of the reason
for that is that people's loyalty wasn't
just based on class it was also based on
their love of nation and so Mussolini
began to marry the concepts of
nationalism with socialism creating if
you will National Socialism later of
course Hitler called himself a national
socialist now what's remarkable is that
now when we look back at all that the
left has performed a kind of sleight of
hand they've taken the socialism out of
national socialism they've forgotten
that these phenomena were on the left
and they've sort of moved them into the
right wing column where they can
conveniently use it to bash Republicans
conservatives and Christians now inertia
in your book the big lie because this is
a big question that Democrats are going
to be asking is a question they asked to
show to goldberg when liberal fascism
came out which is are you really
suggesting that today's Democratic Party
are genocide all monsters who want to
commit Holocaust because is that there
is this sort of rule on the internet
Godwin's law that whoever you know
invoke the Nazis first loses the
argument now there's no question left is
invoke the Nazis first I mean they keep
saying the donald trump is some sort of
Hitlerian proto-fascist but you know the
the question is going to be when you say
that the the Nazi roots of the American
left exists are you suggesting that the
left is okay with the Holocaust are you
suggesting that the modern left would be
okay with the Holocaust what's the well
how do you take on that particular issue
you
after World War two fascism and nazism
became in erratically stained with the
reputation of Holocaust without wits and
so on and we look at those things now in
that way it's almost difficult for us to
understand why anybody would be a
fascist given that this is what fascists
did let's remember that that's not how
fascism was perceived in Italy in the
20s or in Germany in the 30s and so part
of what I try to do is recover that
original meaning of fascism and and of
Nazism even the left when they say the
Trump is a Nazi they're not saying that
Trump has started a world war and killed
six million Jews what they're saying is
that Trump resembles Hitler or circa
in other words Hitler was a demagogue
who promised the restoration of Germany
Trump is promising to make America great
again we're really arguing about fascism
in its sort of original or germinal
phase now what I'm saying is that there
is a whole history of progressivism and
of the Democratic Party being in bed
with fascism and even early Nazism that
was covered up after World War two and I
bring all that secret history to light
in the book from the book again is the
big lie exposing Nazi roots of the
American left to national ask question
for you because I know that you have a
really busy schedule that the book was
just released yesterday so what do you
hope to accomplish with the book because
obviously the left is going to claim
that you're just trying to pander to the
base and that you're trying to sell
books by by using inflammatory language
but what's what's your goal here well my
goal in Hillary's America the previous
book and movie was to take away the race
card from the left which I felt that
they were playing illegitimately against
people us who are not racist and here I
want to take away the fascism part and
not just take it away but expose a whole
facet of American history that as you
may say been swept under the rug I think
if people recognize the fascism is truly
a phenomenon of the left and not of the
right
my book will have done its work the book
again is the big lie exposing the Nazi
roots of the American left it came out
yesterday it's already soaring up the
Amazon best hello let's make it a New
York Times best seller as well
dinesh really enjoying the book um in
the middle of it right now and thanks
for all the great work that you're doing
out there appreciate it my pleasure
okay so
before we go any further I want to
discuss the ramifications of the skin
which we elster and what's going to
happen next with Kelly and I want to
give you the recap on the debate that I
did a chanc yogurt on Sunday as well as
I want to talk about a couple of major
stories that are break inside the Trump
administration plus I want to analyze
that it's tisha bar it's the the most
the most tragic day on the Jewish
calendar let's talk about all of these
things but before I do any of those
things I first want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Lending Tree so
right now if you're looking for somebody
to give you a home loan what people
typically do when they're when they're
looking for a mortgage is they go to
somebody they know that person refers
somebody and then they choose that
person it's all word of mouth you don't
get competitive bids right you get one
person who tells you that this is the
person I use and you may or may not be
getting a good rate you may or may not
be getting a good deal well that's why
Lending Tree is there the average
Lending Tree customer can save twenty
thousand dollars over the life of their
loan that is average which means half
their customers save even more eighty
percent of people only get one mortgage
offer but if you go to Lending Tree and
you fill out their their brief survey
then you're going to get right in front
of you a bunch of competitive offers on
your mortgage like shopping for flights
online only are shopping for the best
mortgage offers for you if you're not
sure that you have the best deal you
need to go today to Lending Tree comm
slash bend that is Lending Tree comm
slash Bend and again I mean I've tried
it out I've looked at the service I
always check out all of our advertisers
to make sure they do what they promised
they do Lending Tree definitely does not
only will you get a bunch of competitive
bids you'll also get the contact
information for all the various people
who were willing to offer you that
you'll get calls from some of them
because they want to reach out to you
that's what Lending Tree does so when it
comes to getting that home loan make
sure that you go to Lending Tree and get
competitive offers they give you all the
various options - you can find out what
it's going to be like for 30-year fixed
or 15-year variable all of the options
are available to you Lending Tree
dot-com / Ben Lending Tree comm / then
make sure you're not getting ripped off
Lending Tree LLC MLS number
11:36 terms and conditions do apply
again the only place where you up to
five real offers from America's top
lenders and you compare them
side-by-side for free and it does take
three minutes it's the quickest process
in the world Lending Tree comm / Ben go
check it out okay so a couple of notes
on the Kelley ouster of scare emoji so
people are treating this as though this
is the beginning of the Trump pivot
right Kelley is coming in Kelley's a
four-star
he is going to take control we talked
about this a little bit yesterday and
him firing Sierra Meucci is obviously
the sign then now someone who's an adult
is in charge there is one problem with
this logic and that is this John Kelly
is now in an unenviable catch-22 we have
seen President Trump operate throughout
his campaign and in his campaign we saw
multiple quote-unquote pivot points
right we saw manna fort was going to
come in take over from Cory Lewandowski
this was going to be the adults in the
room then manna for was ousted and
Bandhan came in and he was going to be
the adult in the room and Callahan
Conway was going to be the adults in the
room and then after the admit he was
going to be the adult in the room and
then they were going to bring in general
Madison general mattis is going to be
the adult in the room now there is a
difference in some of these people right
so mattis obviously is the adult in the
room on defense but he's not in the
White House next to trump every day and
the same thing is true with some of the
other members of the administration
we're doing fine jobs if you're not in
Trump's immediate purview and your job
isn't to control Trump then you can do a
great job right you can be off to the
side doing a wonderful job if however
your job is to is to militate against
Trump's obvious volatility if that is
your job you are in a catch-22 because
if you actually solidified Trump if you
actually get Trump to calm down you're
going to stop tweeting stupid crap and
attack me is attorney general if you get
him to start pursuing legislation
instead of saying random things then one
of two things is going to happen either
Trump is going to settle down ha ha ha
or you're going to be covered in the
media as the guy who got Trump to settle
down right the media is always going to
treat Trump like he's a zoo animal and
so if you're the person who tamed the
lion what happens your face ends up on
the cover of Time magazine just like
Steve Annan and what happened after
bannon's faces on the cover of Time
magazine Trump got pissed at and began
to began to marginalize him because
obviously it was Ben and in control and
not Trump or you got a lot of president
Bannon talk well now you're going to get
a lot of president Kelley talk right
there's an a headline from the onion
that ala pundit over at hot air took
note of this headline over at the onion
said US forces take control of Oval
Office right the idea being the Kelley
it's supposed to be funny right a US
military occupation of the Oval Office
but this is going to be the headline if
things calm down now who's going to get
the credit is it going to be Trump no
and Trump
unlike Harry Truman you know I'm like
Ronald Reagan Harry Truman said the buck
stops here Ronald ring
said you can go you can get incredibly
far when it doesn't matter to you who
takes the credit Trump only cares about
who takes the credit so if Kelly starts
getting credit for calming him down then
Trump is going to angry at Kelly he's
going to lash out at Kelly this is what
he does and if Kelly doesn't calm him
down then nothing is really been
accomplished here and it's going to look
like even even John Kelly a four-star
general wasn't able to get Trump under
control I mean people are grasping at
straws here there's really an attempt I
think to paint this is another Trump
pivot people are saying well at least
Trump isn't tweeting yet guys it's been
like 10 hours it's been like 10 hours I
mean if I of our standards are this low
then we should really think about
whether we need to raise our standards a
little bit it's just not me not not
particularly not particularly smart like
let's wait on this let's find out
whether Kelly can get out listen I hope
and pray Kelly can get this under
control again you have your Republican
president with the Republican House and
Republican Senate things should be
happening it's only going to happen if
Trump gets his crap under control and
the only way that's going to happen is
if he starts listening to the people
around him already you can see that the
pressure is starting if I'm cut rump
tweeted out this morning we look forward
to working alongside general Kelly now
we look forward to to not not I'm really
excited that he's his chief of staff and
we're all going to work for him right
the line was as you saw from Sarah
Huckabee Sanders and Pat Buchanan that
everything was now going to run through
Kelley early in February there was a
report from Vanity Fair that everything
was going to run through Reince Priebus
how well did that work out
if Ivanka and Jared decided walk in the
Oval Office Sean Kelly is not going to
be able to stop them and Trump is not
going to stop them so I think that it's
important to recognize that when there
are gaps in policy not everything is
going to go smoothly so we should just
keep that in mind before we start
celebrating and thinking that all the
all the chaos is past okay meanwhile
some of the Cavs I hope is past and
because there's another story that came
out yesterday that is completely wild
from CNN we'll talk about that in just a
second but for that you're going to have
to go over to Daley wire calm and
subscribe we're not just an audio show
folks who are a video show if you had
only seen the beginning of today's show
you would have realized how important it
is that you subscribe and see the show
live because our visuals today we're
just first-rate thank you production
team but for $9.99 a month you can get
your subscription in the daily wired get
my show live you can watch the rest of
the show live you know if the wait for
it uniformed for an audio you can see it
in part of the mailbag which will be
doing on Friday you can be part of
Andrew Clemens mailbag and watch his
show live
you can watch the new michael mole show
which premiered yesterday god help us I
didn't actually have a chance to watch
it I heard that it was pretty good
I just believe this but I will have a
chance to watch it a little bit later
I've heard that it is it is quite funny
so go over and check that out and you
get the $9.99 subscription that's what
you get so you get all that plus the
website ad free so you don't have any
annoying ads popping up if you get the
annual subscription for $99 you get this
magnificent incredible incomparable
leftist here's hot or cold tumbler it is
just terrific I can vouch for its
quality i caress it in my in these
strong manly hands every single day when
I make this pitch it is just a
spectacular spectacular tumbler I wish I
could drink from it it's a pasty I can't
but you can if you get that annual
subscription so go over to go over to
daily wear right now and make that
happen for yourself get it you deserve a
birthday present make your birthday
present paying us just do it that way
also if you just want to listen later go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud and you can
listen later and leave us a review
subscribe we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
okay so the reason that we hope that
Kelly comes in and provides him so what
it is because this is just a
hysterically amazing story it is from
Siena a self-described email prankster
in the UK fooled a number of White House
officials into thinking he was other
officials including an episode where he
convinced the White House official
tasked with cybersecurity that he was
Jared Kushner and received that
officials private email address
unsolicited Tom we are arranging a bit
of a soiree toward the end of August
fake turd Kushner wrote on an Outlook
account to the official White House
email address of Homeland Security
Adviser Tombaugh sir
it'd be great if you could make it I
promised food of at least comparable
quality to which we ate in Iraq should
be a great evening Basra wrote back
thanks Jared with a promise like that I
can't refuse also if you ever need it my
personal email is and then he gave his
personal email the best thing however is
that he pretended to be Sean Spicer in
an email exchange with Anthony Skinner
Moochie and this is just impressively
incredible masquerading as Ryan Smith
masquerading as that not not Switzer as
previous masquerading as Ryan's previous
the prankster emailed scaramouche's
official account using a mail calm
accounts on Saturday the day after
previous resignation was announced quote
I promised myself I would leave my hands
mud-free wrote fake a previous but after
reading your tweet today which stated
how soon we will learn who in the media
has class and who hasn't has pushed me
to this that's who it was breathtakingly
hypocritical even for you
and then scare Moochie very real scary
move he replied you know what you did we
all do even today but rest assured we
were prepared a man would apologize
take previous wrote back I can't believe
you're questioning my ethics the so
called mooch who can't even manage his
first week in the White House without
leaving upset in his wake I have nothing
to apologize for
Ciara Moochie replied read Shakespeare
particularly Othello you are right there
my family is fine by the way and will
thrive I know what you did no more
replies from me also he pretended to be
the ambassador to Russia designate John
Huntsman and he wrote to and he wrote to
Sierra Moochie whose head should roll
first meaning Bannon or previous and
real scaramouche II wrote back both of
them hey this is all written to just a
prankster who used their public
government email address and wrote to
them pretending to be another government
official just amazing stuff guys please
for the love of God get better
I'm very fearful that you are going to
write an email to another member of the
Trump administration they're going to
actually give you the nuclear launch
codes like you must get better at this
also worth noting when when the head of
cybersecurity is handing out his
personal email address I seem to
remember this is not a good idea I think
to remember like a three-year-long
scandal because a particularly who
random democratic party was using a
private email address and private email
server for political business don't do
this people please don't do this John
Kelly please please take control for the
love of God please take control I beg of
you please do it another bad story out
of the White House today I don't want it
to all be bad news because I think that
I hope that John Kelly is going to take
control there's a lawsuit that's out
today you don't know who to trust in
this sort of thing lawsuits all the time
but now there is a lawsuit that is
suggesting the plaintiff is rod wheeler
his opossum News contributor former
homicide investigator and he is now
claiming that President Trump himself
works with Fox News and a wealthy
Republicans owner to push the south rich
murder story I hope that isn't true
because if so that's really gross but
well we'll give you more information if
more information breaks on that score
okay so for those of you who aren't able
to actually come out to my debate with
Chang cougar it was I thought it was a
great event 3,000 people showed up for
the event they to move the venue because
so many people showed up about 2,000
people were fans of the show fans of
mine which is really fun and unexpected
in the past debates including Chang have
really been changstarr me outnumbering
whoever the conservative is people like
the Nash people like Ann Coulter but I
thought the debate was actually really
substantive I was not expecting it to be
substantive to be completely honest with
you I was expecting it to look a lot
more like shanks debate with an
ordinarily Dinesh where it was really a
shank taking some piece that someone
wrote ten years ago using it out of
context and then turning to the crowd
and calling them erases that actually
didn't happen it turned out to be a
pretty substantive debate I want to give
you some of the highlights in case you
weren't able to see it you can watch the
whole thing on YouTube
I was trending all day on YouTube
yesterday it's trending all day on
YouTube today hundreds of thousands of
handsome millions if it's actually at
this point when you aggregate them for
this debate which I thought was really
an important debate and actually useful
important to MIT we talked about health
care and taxes here are just a few of I
thought the best moments for me and here
is my explanation of capitalism shank
contended that Kimsey anism was the was
the best possible solution to making
economic prosperity happen here was me
debunking that the the problem of King
Jian economics is that it doesn't even
work in theory because again once you go
to the logical extreme which is remove
all of the money from the rich people
who are saving all their money and give
it to all the poor people to buy
hamburgers that doesn't help the economy
or spur the economy what Spurs the
economy is a higher level but
but Spurs the economy is the creation of
new products and services and that is
only going to be done by people who have
expendable capital to actually invest in
new products and services that we all
enjoy what creates economic growth it's
also worth noting that this myth that
spending is inherently better for an
economy than saving that's only true if
you're talking about somebody's actually
taking the cash for just shoving it into
their mattress banks are in the business
of lending when they take the money in
they go just stick it in Al Gore's fake
lockbox they actually lend the money
back out to people to actually create
new businesses a new product you had an
investor right when you start at TYT
you're given four million dollars my
buddy roemer to start qit that's great
that's the way business should work
right but that money has then come from
bunch of poor people buying hamburgers
it came from a very very wealthy guy who
gave you money to create a business a
lot of people want to patronize if you
want better products and better services
you need more investment in the products
and services the basic name triple down
economics
the basic name circle down economics is
not something that any conservative even
proposed it's a leftist revision of what
economics actually is because you're not
giving me the money it was my money in
the first place
created through voluntary transactions
that I had with others I've not stolen
money from either from anyone neither
have you and the idea that money has to
be forcibly taken from you and handed to
somebody at the bottom end of the
economic spectrum to somehow job the
economy that made job McDonald's but
it's not going to job all of the
creation of the products and services
that make all of our lives much better
today than they were 30 years ago in
terms of the stuff we have access to so
as I say I think there was a really
substantive interesting debate I wanted
to make a few notes about Medicare
because chanc was talking a lot about
Medicare in this debate he talked a lot
about the glories of Medicare how
popular it was just because the program
is popular doesn't mean the program is
actually good I talked about the cost of
Medicare there's a 43 trillion dollar
outstanding debt on Medicare that's how
much money it's going to cost the United
States according to a columnist over at
National Review I want to get his name
Michael tanner this is a he gives some
good statistics on all of this he points
out that not only is there 60 billion
dollars in fraud and improper payments
in Medicare per year but right now if
somebody pays into Medicare 10 kept
saying you pay into Medicare you get out
of Medicare what you pay into Medicare
is not what you get out of Medicare a
married couple with two average earners
turning 65 and 2020 will pay about 150
thousand dollars in Medicare payroll
taxes over their lifetime given their
life expectancy they can expect to
receive almost five hundred thousand
dollars in benefits that means that
you're going to spend an enormous amount
of money beyond that Medicare is not
actually doing that great a job because
a lot of doctors are not accepting
Medicare anymore they won't set new
Medicare patients because Medicare
reimbursement rates are simply too low
so just because there is Medicare
doesn't mean that everybody takes
Medicare which is why a lot of people
are forced to pay out-of-pocket it is
also true that according to according
this column not only will this force
even more physicians out of the program
according to the actuaries at the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services the combination of effect leads
to roughly half of hospitals 70% of
skilled nursing facilities and 90% of
home health agencies losing money by
2040 which will lead to widespread
closures you pay people too little money
and they're not going to actually
succeed also the Journal of American
Medical Association has found that for
16 of 40
and indicators Medicare patients
received less recommended less care than
two-thirds of the time the rest of the
less care then recommended two thirds of
the time other studies have shown that
Medicare patients receive a lower
quality of care than do similar patients
with private health insurance a journal
study in the Journal of Health Services
found Medicare coverage at 65 for the
previously uninsured is not linked to
improvements in overall health status
we've seen that with Medicaid as well
there is no advantage to actually being
on Medicaid in terms of life expectancy
and health outcome so probably talk
about Medicare for all it costs a lot of
money and it ain't that effective and it
drives doctors out of the program it
leads to rationing by the way as I've
said before I don't believe that the
government should be involved in health
care health care is an individual
decision that you make and there should
be a social fabric that picks up the
pieces for people can't afford for
themselves but if you were to have some
sort of program the most effective
program in terms of health insurance is
the Swiss Program the Switzerland
mandated program where you all buy
health insurance just like car insurance
but it's almost entirely privatized the
problem there is that the number of
people who are not able to get the
insurance that they want to get is like
31 percent because obvious debate when
it comes to health care you can only
have when it comes to health insurance
in health care about both of these
things well health care really when it
comes to health care you can only have
three things right
you know affordability universality
quality you can have two of those three
you cannot have all three Obamacare has
created more universality it has not
created more quality and it is not
created more affordability and chain
kept saying no no you can have it all
you can have a cheap you can have an
effective you can have it for everybody
no that's not true because there's no
area in life where you can make
something cheap and effective for
everybody unless you have a free-market
system driving prices down in quality up
anytime you have a mandate all that does
is it drives the quality down and the
price is up which is exactly what's
happened with Obamacare other things
from the debate that were fun there was
a Shanks big thing is he doesn't like
money in politics and I was pointing out
to him that money will always be in
politics and that's not a bad thing
considering that we spend lots of money
here at the Daily wire on bringing you
political material Chang spends a lot of
money over at TYT bringing people
political material pretending to my $200
donation to a candidate is the same
thing as Chang spending millions of
dollars to bring his particular
political view to the public which
definitely Ford's the agenda of
particular politicians that's just silly
money is a form of speech
we all know this because this is why we
wouldn't allow the government to come in
and shut down the New York Times on the
ground that hey after all they're just
spending money it is in speech I made
this point to changqin rather colorful
fashion your government is in the
business of regulating business what
would be the problem with the government
telling Buddy Roemer he is not allowed
to invest in your business no that is no
no's a true termination is no problem no
problem
no it is one thing is to say hey let's
set reasonable limitations on what can
happen around elections which is again
what most developed Western countries do
so and they have different versions of
that rule there's ads you can run you
can't run as within a certain period of
time your public financing versus
private financing those are rules around
an election that is completely different
issue than the government saying
randomly you can and can't invest in
businesses while you're conflating those
two issues that have nothing new with
one another why so let's just out work
we remember why me it has Gozer because
hey why you know you believe in
education I believe in health care
because it's a because it's a free
country and I get to spend my money
wherever I damn well please
and then finally Chang had said
something he was trying to make a
distinction between money and speech
when it comes to politics and so he said
well if money is just speech then why
isn't all money just speech well money
for political speech is political speech
money on other things is not but in any
case he compared it to prostitution he
said well if money is just speech then
why can't I just you know go spend money
on a hooker and call it speech here was
my response when you say money in
politics that again I asked you buddy
roemer gave you four million dollars to
start TYT what did he expect in return
should he not have given you money was
money not speech it was just money i
Prost with a hooker I assume so argue
the prostitute how's this one
yeah it got interesting so if you missed
the whole thing then you can go and
check it out on YouTube we also have it
up on my Facebook page as well we are
releasing clips of it too it was it was
a lot of fun it's about an hour long she
shouldn't take too much of your time but
we'll be releasing some of the better
clips from it as time progresses okay
time for some things I like and then
some things I hate and then I want to
talk about tisha Bob which is the the
Jewish fast day that we are that we are
participating in today so things I like
so we have been paying tributes of
scarer Moochie I didn't know is gonna be
fired yesterday but we started our
tribute to skirmish yesterday with Wall
Street today I want to pay tribute to
scare Lucci with another with eight with
another clip from movie that is just
very scary Lucci this of course would be
the same Terry Ellis from die hard one
of my favorite characters in film
history and you will see the mooch and
all of his mannerisms and all of his
speech and it is just phenomenal hope
I'm not interrupting what is here on
it's not what I want is what I can give
you
boy let's be straight okay it's obvious
you're not some dumb schmuck up here to
snatch a few purses am i right
you're very perceptive I watch 60
minutes I say to myself you guys are
professional they're motivated they're
happening ie they want something huh now
personally I couldn't care less a bunch
of politics have you pissed off at the
camel jockeys maybe it's the heaves
northern Alan it's none of my business I
figure you here to negotiate am i right
you're amazing you figured this all out
already hey hey
business is business you use a gun I use
a fountain pen what's the difference put
it in my terms you're hearing a hostile
takeover you grabbed us for some green
mail but you didn't expect some poison
pill was going to be running around the
building am i right Hans Bobby I'm your
white knight must have missed 60 minutes
- what'd I say my god stairs things up
huh I can give him give ya so now watch
die hard what unfortunately what happens
to to the mooch in this movie is also
what happened to mooch politically so
things go very poorly for me I wonder
what happened to Hart botcher our
posture had a bit of a career being like
a jerk he was he's in a great movie that
I've recommended on the show before
called called Breaking Away he's a
villain in that movie as well he's just
terrific in it I'm not sure what he's
been doing lately apparently a lot of TV
I'm looking up his IMDB right now looks
like a lot of TV stuff but he's not in
it he hasn't been in a lot of big stuff
really since the 80s they starting to do
a lot more TV like in the last three or
four years I miss you heart botcher come
back and play the mooch I mean come on
it's most obvious casting of all times
probably a little old for the part now
but fantastic in any case okay time for
some things that I hate
so the first thing I hate is the
Democrats the left they just can't stop
they can't stop with the the comparisons
that are that are actually insulting so
when I do all of this it's all in love
okay it's all is all in fun I mean this
is all ridiculous the left treats Trump
like he's an actual dictators is Dinesh
said before they try to suggest that
he's Hitler in Chris Matthews about to
freeze for him for you Chris Matthews on
everybody say you study about Trump
purging administration and kind of like
you know it's kind of up to worst
dictators in history purging the
administration take me by shooting him
during the ditch during the type of
river letting wash up later a bloody and
disgusting Trumpy the words that Kim
Jung a go with the regularity of the
nightly news president Trump is throwing
bodies out of the White House at a rate
that matches the Russian Revolution I
think all this going around and purging
people just like Kim jung-un what is he
doing knocks off always relatives when
he gets scared when you get scared of
your position you start killing people
around it we don't do that in this
country we fire them Trump seems to know
how to fire that's my argument my
argument is you terrible person I get
for the morning I look at my hair it's
all messed up get a show breasts my
everything show job better out myself
and I start things you like kim jungeun
well not really I'm going to say it
anyway because come on is inflammatory
Mussolini Hitler Kim Jong un boo Chris
Matthews MSNBC so I'm again Democrats
you might want to just point out the
fact that this is more incompetence than
it is malevolence it's not like you
brought in the mooch because he wanted
to kill the mood which okay he brought
in the mood because the mood was wildly
entertaining and again I am so sad about
all of this I mean you don't get rid of
the Fonz before he can become your
breakout character he was your uncle he
was your the Fonz you don't get rid of
the breakout character guys come on come
on
okay the other thing that I hate Jeffery
Lord comes out and he says that when it
comes to Trump they're talking about how
Trump spoke at this police academy and
he said something about how you know if
you're putting people in the car and you
don't put your hand on top of their head
that's okay that's okay
they just killed somebody you know okay
whatever and people oh he's for police
brutality I think Jeffery Lord is right
about this but I want to make a point
about what Jeffrey the Lord says Jeffery
Lord says this is just trumping in New
Yorker I think
to actually correct here is ear Lord
okay I have to say he's in New Yorkers
standing in front of New Yorkers on Long
Island my whole family's from Rockman
that's the way they talked okay that's
100% true so I was in New York last week
and I was walking along the street and
there was a shirt that said that this is
literally what the shirt said it's just
in a store window fu you effing eff
right that's what the shirt said and I
thought this could not be on sale
anywhere else in the United States like
legitimately nowhere else in the United
States who do there be anyone who buys
this shirt this shirt is probably a best
seller in New York and that's why Trump
won he won because the rest of the
United States takes his tough talk and
his brash nonsense really seriously in
New York is just a cabdriver
everyone talks like Trump in New York
right when people are doing the well the
mooch is copying Trump's hand motions
with all this stuff no the mooch is just
from New York okay so people from New
York talk like this and that's why
nobody from New York takes Trump all
that seriously but in the rest of the
country uses this inflammatory language
and everybody goes oh you must mean it
because around here oh and we see f you
you effing eff you must have like punch
my sister in the face or something for
me to say that no in New York that just
means that you're standing in line in
front of me and you didn't move up
quickly enough in the line right so
that's why it's not worthwhile taking
Trump's rhetoric super seriously on the
stuff like oh he's calling for police
brutality no he's just a guy from New
York okay so today is in fact despite
the show today is in fact the most
solemn day on the Jewish calendar it's
why Jews have been fasting from last
night to tonight no food no water that's
real bad glass but but tisha Bob the
reason that it is the it is the most
solid in a Jewish calendar a bunch of
bad things - traditionally happened on -
Shabaab to the Jewish people so in 1313
BCE spies returned from the promised
land and gave a bad report about the
promised land in 423 BCE the first
temple was destroyed on the Temple Mount
in seven DCE the second temple was
destroyed on the Temple Mount in 1492
the Jews were expelled from Spain's the
state has some sort of particular cosmic
significance obviously when it comes to
God now I want to talk a little bit
about what the significance of the day
is aside from bad things happen today to
the Jews so we commemorate that so the
typical lesson from tisha Bob which
means the ninth of of it's the month of
oven the Jewish calendar it's you know
Jesus would have would have would have
celebrated the month Bob for Christians
out there and it's just have Jewish
calendar works it's the ninth of object
and the most famous story in the Talmud
about this I talks about why it was the
temple was destroyed so we don't tend to
do this now
now when bad things happen when world
events happen we tend not to attribute
them to specific causes in the past that
was much more common if you read the
rise and fall of the Roman Empire the
the authored given he goes out of his
way to actually try and explain what the
causes are for the fall of the Roman
Empire we today something bad happens we
don't know what was the cause of that we
just assume that it happened in Jewish
philosophy there's a thought which is
the Second Temple fell because what we
called C not phenom meaning unrooted
hatred I just hatred for no reason and
there's a story about what that meant in
the times the time it's an apocryphal
story but it's kind of informative so
the story goes like this
there was a banquet in Jerusalem at the
time of the Second Temple and there's a
very rich wealthy guy who had an enemy
whose name was whose name was Bar
khamseh he also had a friend who's in
with Kamsa he had this big feast and he
wanted to invite Compson his friend
instead he invited Bar khamseh biaxin
and his messenger went to the wrong guy
once a bar Kamsa and bar khamseh shows
up at his feet thinking okay we're going
to make nice now they see bar khamseh
sits down he starts eating and me and
the guy who's throwing fees comes up to
me because what the hell are you doing
here I don't want you here you're a jerk
and bar comes to listen you know now
you're there are lots of people here I
don't want to be humiliated you throwing
me out of here I'll pay for my own meal
I'll give you money I'll get to stay
here was what's the you know what's the
problem and guy says no I want you out
of here forthwith bar Thomson was so
angry about this and so angry there were
a bunch of rabbis there who didn't
actually do anything that he immediately
went to the Romans and apparently gave
them security information about the way
that the the Jewish rebellion that the
way the Jewish rule was working and and
then supposedly gave them the impetus to
come in and destroy the temple and just
rend dispersed the Jewish people that's
the story it's apocryphal right I mean
there's not a lot of historic evidence
that's the way that it happened but that
is the story the way that it happens in
the Talmud so what does that mean that
doesn't seem like baseless hatred right
it seems like Barr commsta has a pretty
solid case that something bad happened
to him but here I think is the point of
that particular story and we should take
it to heart because it has some impact
on politics in the United States and for
Western civilization and that is
baseless hatred is about you attributing
motives to people that you don't
actually know
that's what baseless hatred is because
if you know what somebody's motive is
then you have a good reason to hate them
if they did something wrong to you you
hate them that seems not like c9p Nam it
seems just like xenon it just seems like
anger and hatred but the point here is
this this guy was so angry at the person
who wronged him that he decided the
entire society had to pay society at
large was responsible for the sins of
this one man
and therefore society at large had to
pay the system was corrupt and bad
things wouldn't happen in a / in a non
corrupt system therefore the system had
to be torn down this is always the
danger to systems of thought it's the
danger to Judaism it's the danger to
Christianity people do this all the time
and see an Orthodox Jew who does bad
things and they say well he's a bad guy
therefore Orthodox Judaism must be false
he's just a Christians all the time that
guy says he's a Christian but did you
see what happened to those priests in
the Catholic Church Christianity must be
complete nonsense if people can do stuff
like that
you can't attribute to a system the
actions of an individual people do this
with America all the time
individual active racism it's because
America is racist therefore America must
be destroyed and replaced by something
better that destroys the temple that
destroys the temple the idea the temple
can still be pure even if people who
visit the temple or participate in
services is the temple or give money to
the temple or not and we need to
identify individual sins for what they
are rather than attributing to a broader
society the motivations of the sin if we
don't do that we are engaging in
baseless hatred not only against one
another but against the society at large
and that's what tears down civilization
ok so I will send the rest of the day in
fasting in prayer which is one of the
things that we do and I hope that you
have a more enjoyable day than we will
and we will be back tomorrow to discuss
all the latest in the ongoing circus
that is American politics I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]